Hi, welcome back. In the last session,
we looked at measuring risk in fixed
income in buying a bond. In this one,
I'd like to focus on the risk you face
when you invest in equity. Equity in a
private business, equity in a publicly
traded company, or more specifically,
equity when you buy stocks. Let's start
with a basic definition of what makes
equity equity. Equity is a residual
claim. you get whatever's left over
after everybody else has been paid. So
when you invest in equity, there are two
things that make it different than fixed
income or bonds. The first is you get
upside and downside. Put simply, you
lose when things don't go as well as
expected, but you share in the upside if
things go better than expected. That
makes it different from fixed income.
And in general, you could argue that
investing in equity exposes you to more
risk than investing in bonds issued by
the same company because you're always
the last person in line. With all that
said though, when you invest in equity
and you face this higher risk, the only
way you can cover yourself, protect
yourself is by demanding a higher
expected return, which you do by setting
a lower price for the investment. The
higher the risk you face, the greater
the expected return should be. In this
session, I'd like to at least introduce
you to two ideas that I think will help
you put a number on the risk of equity.
The first is the measure of an equity
risk premium, which is a premium you
demand for investing in equities as a
class. The second is a measure of
relative risk where you could look at an
individual stock and say this is more
risky or less risky than the average
stock. So let's start with the price of
equity risk. Equities are collectively
more risky than bonds. We said that
already. Might as well emphasize that.
So over long periods you should expect
to earn a premium for investing in
equities if you're a rational investor.
We're not always rational, but
collectively, let's assume that
rationality holds. That premium you
demand over and above what you can make
on a guaranteed investment, a risk-free
rate, is called an equity risk premium.
There are two ways in which you can
estimate this equity risk premium. The
way in which most people get it and
especially in the US is to look
backwards. Look at 50, 80, 100 years of
history and look at what stocks have
earned over that period relative to
something risk-free. the historical risk
premium. The other, and this is an
approach that I prefer, is to let the
markets tell you what the equity risk
premium is. You're saying, "How would
the markets tell you?" When you pay a
price for a stock, you're telling me
what your expected risk premium is
through the price you pay. I can back
out of stock prices an implied equity
risk premium, a forward-looking number
that can be dynamic. Let's start with
historical risk premiums. Historical
risk premium, as I said, is a premium
that stocks have earned. historically
over riskless securities. Now your
response might be last year that didn't
happen. Over last 5 years it did not
happen. That might be true. But over the
very long term stock should be expected
to earn more than a riskless investment.
So people look at a long period of
history 50 years 80 years 100 years they
look on average what stocks made over
that period. Let's say 8% a year. They
look on average at what bonds or
something riskless made over that
period. 3%. 8 minus 3 is 5%. That's a
historical risk premium. Now, the way
you compute the averages can cause the
risk premiums to be different because if
you look at a compounded average, money
makes money on money, you get a lower
number than an arithmetic average. If
you use the T bill, a short-term
government investment is risk-free, you
get a different premium than long-term.
Using a different time period, 50 versus
100 years will give you a different risk
premium. So point I'm making is
historical risk breams are often viewed
as facts but they're estimates that are
sensitive to the choices you make
focusing just in the US. I do update
these historical risk frames though I
don't use them at the start of every
year. So this is my data going back to
1928 where I look at stocks over and
above T- bills and stocks over and above
T- bonds arithmetic averages versus
geometric averages and you can see the
equity risk premium while always
positive at least in this table ranges
from a low of you know 5.44% to a high
of 12.34% or even 13.5%.
Clearly your equity risk premiums your
historical premiums can be different
depending on your choices. In addition,
these are all estimates. What does that
mean? They come with noise. They come
with a standard error. And the italics
you see there tell you how much the
standard error is. In case that that
doesn't grab you, that 2.12% standard
error for a for 96 year old historical
risk premium. Here's how it'll play out.
If you tell me your risk premium over
that period is 5.44%, that's a stocks
versus T-Bonds. And the standard error
is 2.12%.
If this were a statistics class, the
true equity risk premium could be a
number from 1 to 10% plus or minus two
standard errors. Now you see why I don't
particularly care for historical risk
premiums. Now to the resp the question
of what's the choice. You can back out
from stock prices what the equity risk
premium is today. What are we doing?
We're essentially calculating for stocks
what we do for bonds. Yield to maturity
in a bond is that discount rate that
makes the present value of the cash
flows in the bond equal to the price of
the bond. If you did that with stocks,
you take the stock index prices today,
you take the expected cash flow is a
little messier because these are not
coupons. They can be expected to change
over time. And unlike a bond which has a
finite life, stocks can go on forever.
But you can still, if you're willing to
make the estimates, compute a discount
rate that makes the present value of the
expected cash flows equal to the level
of the index today. What does that give
you? It tells you what investors are
expecting to make on stock in the long
term given what they're paying. There's
no theory here. It is a pragmatic
estimate of what people are pricing in.
That implied equity risk premium will
change on a day-to-day basis, week-
toeek basis. Why? as the index changes,
cash flows change, risk-free rates
change. So when you look at the equity
risk, it's that expected return you get
from this calculation net of the
risk-free rate. Now we can have a long
debate about what's risk- free, but
essentially look on look on the
risk-free rate is what you can make on a
guaranteed investment. So at the start
of 2025, I tried this out as I have at
the start of every month since 2008,
start of every year going back to the
1990s. I took the level of the index
5881.63.
I projected out the expected cash flows
and here I needed some help from
analysts for projected earnings from
historical data on what percentage of
those earnings get paid out as dividends
or in buybacks. And then I solve for a
discount rate. It's a sol you can use
the solver function in Excel to do it.
The expected return I got is 8.91%.
What does it tell me [clears throat] at
the start of 2025?
If you bought US stocks, you could
expect to make a return of 8.91% a year.
Forward-looking dynamic. You subtract
out the risk-free rate, the T- bond rate
on that day of 4.58%.
The implied equity risk premium is
4.33%.
So that is basically the price of risk
in the equity market. And that price
will vary over time. During crisis,
you'll see that price pop up. The
implied equity risks go up. In good
times, it'll tend to go down. And you
can get a sense of that volatility by
looking at this graph that looks at
implied equity risk premium for the for
the S&P 500 going back to 1960. In this
graph, you see the crisis in 2008.
There's the 19 late7s. You also see the
dotcom boom where people lost all
perspective and thought of equities as
very safe. This is a dynamic
forward-looking number. It's a number
that you can think of as the price of
risk in the equity market. what what the
market is giving you as a reward for
investing in equities as a class
that settles the overall equity price of
risk but individual stocks can be safer
or riskier than the average stock in the
market. So you need a measure of
relative risk and there are three ways
in [clears throat] which people have
approached differentiating cross stocks.
I'll start with theory based models. We
start with theory about what investors
should demand and back into a model. And
then I look at how as data has become
more accessible, people have shifted
away from theory to data and let the
data tell them what's risky or safe.
You're saying how can that do how can
the data do that? Well, when you look at
stocks that have gone up more than other
stocks over long periods, you could
argue that those stocks must have been
riskier. And finally, we'll look at
alternatives to traditional
finance-based models, either intuitive
or qualitative based measures of risk.
[clears throat]
Let's start with theory based models.
And theory based models usually start by
defining risk in terms of variance of
actual returns around expected returns.
You say, what does that mean? When you
invest in something, you have an
expected return 8 n 10%. If that return
is always going to be what you expected,
that's the definition of risk rate. But
to the extent that the actual returns
can be higher or lower than that than
that expected return, you have risk. One
thing to emphasize is almost all of the
theory based models in finance are bu
are look at risk through the eyes of the
marginal investor in a company rather
than you or I as individual investors.
You think what does that mean? Marginal
investors are investors who own a large
portion of the stock and trade
frequently.
Most US stocks that will that's likely
to be an institutional investor. You're
saying so what an institutional investor
is usually diversified. It changes your
perspective on risk because it looks at
risk as the risk added on to the
portfolio and the risk standing alone.
Something we talked about in the context
of the introduction to risk.
The model that's been around the longest
theorybased model is the capital asset
pricing model or the CAPM. It's built in
if you if you think of the derivation of
the model without getting into the
specifics, it's built on four building
blocks. It starts by assuming live in
what's called a mean variance world.
What does that mean? As investors, we
like higher returns. We don't like
variance. And we stop. That's it. That's
all we care about. That's pretty that's
a little unrealistic, but that's your
starting point. Second, it assumes you
can trade freely. No transactions cost,
no brokerage cost, no bid ass spreads.
Again, unrealistic.
It assumes there's no private
information, things you can trade on to
make a guaranteed return. Again,
unrealistic. But if you make those
assumptions, all of the
non-diversifiable risk in the market can
be captured by one factor, which is a an
overall market index, a fully
diversified portfolio.
If you use those building blocks,
there's no reason to ever stop
diversifying. there's no transactions
cost and you can't pick the right
stocks. Why stop? So your portfolio ends
up with every single traded asset in it
and the risk of an asset becomes a risk
it adds to that portfolio. We call that
the market portfolio. Statistically that
risk can be captured by coariance. How
your stock moves with the market and
that covariance is standardized by
dividing by the variance of the market
gives you the beta. When you use beta,
you're carrying a lot of luggage with
you. But a beta gives [clears throat]
you a measure of risk in a company
scaled around one. A beta 1 is average
risk. Beta above one is above average
risk. And all of the risk is relative to
a market index. That's a CAPM still
widely used because it is so simple, so
easy. And in fact, to get that beta, we
use a regression. A regression of
returns in the stock against returns in
a market index. this case I've I've
reproduced a Bloomberg beta for
Microsoft and you can see the raw beta
of 0.88 88 that is the beta according to
the regression and there's a whole lot
of finessing that happens around this
but that is the CAPM you measure the
risk of a stock with a single number and
that number if you compare it to one
tells you whether your stock is below
average or above average risk
and the CAPM withtood a lot of criticism
over the last 50 years to still remain
in use but you could see the assumptions
are unrealistic but there are some
misconceptions about beta among people
who use beta is that we want I want to
get out of the way. Now first beta is
not a measure of total risk. It's a
measure of risk added to a portfolio.
You can have a risky stock that has a
low beta if it doesn't move with the
market. Second, there's a myth that beta
is a is a statistical measure because it
comes out of regression. It's not. You
might use statistics a regression to
estimate it, but your beta comes from
choices a company makes. what business
to be in, what its fixed costs look
like, its financial leverage.
There's this presumption among many
people who use betas, especially if they
get the beta from a surface, that it's a
fact. No, it's an estimate. In fact, if
you go to the previous page, see the
standard error of the beta 0105 that
basically tell puts a number on how much
of an estimate it is. And finally,
there's some there are some investors
who seem to think bait measure
investment quality that bait has
replaced you as a stock picker. No, they
don't. It's a measure of risk. They
don't tell you what's cheap, what's
expensive, what's good, what's bad for
your portfolio. That's still up to you.
I know a lot of people use betas as a
shield to not do fundamental analysis,
to not ask questions. I don't like the
CAPM, therefore I'm not going to do
that. You can not like beta and still
stay in a space where you ask the right
questions about risk.
Now
the CAPM withtood a lot of counter
models for a period and late '7s one of
the models that came about that looked
like it was going to be a lifesa saver
was called the arbitrage pricing model.
What does the arbitrage pricing model
do? It starts with the same building
blocks as a cap. But it assumes one
thing which is that if there are
multiple investors in a market and
there's a way to make money without risk
that will go away because those
investors will arbitrage it away. In
effect the only real difference between
the CAPM and the arbitrage pricing model
is rather than build the assumptions
into having one factor the market be the
single factor it allows for multiple
sources of market risk. risk you can't
diversify away. Those sources will tend
to be macroeconomic risk forces.
Inflation, slope of the yield curve, how
the economy is doing. And the way you
identify them is by looking at the data
and looking to see what how as those
variables change your stock does. So
it's called a factor analysis where you
look at returns on stocks across long
periods and you look at macro factors
and you try to find how many factors are
driving stock prices and what the beta
is against each factor.
In many ways factor analysis pushes
statistics again to the forefront but
the expected return on a stock can then
be written as a risk-free rate. The
starting point is the same but instead
having one beta and the market index at
the equity risk premium you have
multiple betas one against each factor
and equity risk premiums against each
factor. The arbitrage pricing model is a
more generic look, you know, more
general version of the capac, but it's
still theory based. But the arbitrage
pricing model opened the door to looking
at data. And in fact in the years after
the arbitrage pricing model came about
because the factors and the risk
premiums are against unspecified
macroeconomic factors there was an
attempt to put names on these factors
where essentially you looked at the data
and said that looks a lot like inflation
that looks a lot like the economy and
essentially it ends up with an equation
that looks very much like the arbitrage
pricing model but now instead of the
betas being against unspecified factors
you actually name the factors
CAPM single factor the market is the
factor arbitrage pricing model multiple
factors and multiple betas but you don't
know what the factors are the
statistical factors factor one factor
two multifactor models those factors now
get names those are the theory based
models and especially as we dug deeper
and deeper into factor models and we
allowed for data people started asking
question why are we even building risk
and return models. Why don't we let the
market tell us what's risky and say
you're saying how does that work? Let's
say I gave you 50 years or 100 years of
returns in individual stocks and then
you looked at stocks that earned higher
returns, average returns, low returns.
You could do that, right? And let's say
that you could then make the assumption
that if stocks earn much higher returns
than average over long periods, they
must be riskier because in effect you're
assuming markets are right in the long
term. You then look for characteristics
that those stocks share. Maybe they
have, you know, they're smaller
companies, maybe they're more assetbased
companies. In other words, you look for
things that they share and those
characteristics that they share are
called factors. And then you build those
factors as risk factors in developing
expected returns. You have no idea what
I'm talking about, right? The first and
perhaps still the most widely cited
paper that's that opened this door was
by Gene Farmer and Ken French in the
early 1990s where they looked at a very
long historical data set of returns and
they found after discarding beta they
said betas don't explain much of the
variation in returns. They found two
factors, two characteristics that
companies that earned higher return
shared. One was they tend to be smaller
companies in terms of market cap,
smaller market cap companies earned
higher returns than larger market cap
companies. They found that low price to
book stocks earned higher returns and
high price to book stocks. And then they
made a leap of faith. That must mean
that smaller companies and lower price
to book companies must be riskier. In
fact, that paper yielded a regression
where they related the returns on
individual stocks, the market cap of the
company and price to book. You're
saying, "How would I use that?" You plug
in your company's market cap and price
to book on that regression, you get an
expected return for your stocks. In
fact, as data on stocks has become
richer and more detailed, the number of
factors that claim to explain difference
in returns is mushroom dozens of
factors. In fact, it's led to some
calling it the factor zoo and
questioning whether in fact we're
finding real factors or whether we're
doing data mining. I will leave that
question for the moment because it's
going to underly a lot of the research
you see as you go through this class.
So you got f theory based models, you
got databased models. The third set of
models are models which are built around
different ways of thinking about equity
risk. The traditional models look at
both upside and downside volatility and
treat them equally. They're based on
market prices rather than fundamentals.
And they do have this big focus on
looking at risk through the eyes of a
diversified investor. And there are many
who find those as those building blocks
to be troublesome. So I'm going to talk
generically about alternative models for
equity risk and and not not in much
depth because those alternative models
can be based on accounting data instead
of market price data. They can be called
proxy models which are spin-offs of
factor models where you use something to
stand in for risk. It could be something
like sector tech companies are riskier
than utilities. Why? Because I know I
know so and you can have market implied
models which are very similar to what we
did for the implied cost of implied
equity risk premium but it's done at the
sector specific level or even the
company specific level. And there are
some people who think that we shouldn't
be adjusting expected returns. We should
be adjusting our earnings for risk and
cash flows. Let's start with accounting
based measures. In accounting based risk
measures, you look at some kind of an
accounting ratio. I'll give you a couple
that people tend to focus on. One is
debt risk. They argue that companies
that are riskier when they borrow money
must be riskier also in equity. So if
you are a lowly rated company, remember
we talked about bond ratings AAA down to
you know triple C double C they argue
that a triple C rated company should
have a higher expected return for its
equity a cost of equity.
Now other way in which accounting
numbers can be used is you can look at
earnings variability over time that
companies with more variable earnings
and the rest of the market should be
riskier. But remember when you use
accounting data there is one compromise
you have to make. you don't have the
amount of data you have or the or the
timeliness of data because accounting
data gets updated in the US at least
four times a year. There's actually a
variant where people compute what's
called an accounting beta where you run
a regression of changes in earnings at
your company against changes in earnings
against the market index. You get a
number that looks like a beta but again
with far fewer data points. You can use
proxy based models where you you know
earlier I talked about farmer and French
who found low price to book and small
market cap and essentially there you can
small companies are riskier than larger
companies. Why? Because the data says so
and as I said oh in the years since
there are other variables that have come
forward earnings momentum companies with
earnings momentum where earnings are
going up faster seem to do better than
companies without them. price momentum.
Companies whose stock prices have gone
up in the in the recent past earn higher
returns liquidity. In fact, you could
argue that many investment philosophies
are built around these phenomena that
people have observed over time. So in a
proxy model, you're letting something
else sit in for risk and you really
don't even need to justify why it has
to. You just say because the data says
so. The third set of models are market
implied models. So to understand how a
market implied model works, we do what
we did with implied equity risk
premiums. We start with the stock price.
We project out a cash flow and we solve
for a discount rate. So this is a very
simplistic example. Let's assume you
have a stable dividend paying stock
which is trading at $20 per share. It's
the market price. It's expected to pay a
dividend of a dollar next year and that
dividend is expected to grow 3% a year
in perpetuity. Well, it's a stable
growth dividend paying stock. If it's
priced right, the $20 should be the $1
in dividends next year divide by the
cost of equity minus the 3% growth rate.
Only unknown there is the R, the
discount rate. You solve for it. You get
an implied expected return. One problem
though is if I plug this back in to the
equation, I'm going to find the stock is
correctly priced. So what people using
this approach tend to do is they tend to
do this across a lot of stocks in a
sector and end up with expected returns
by sector that are implied expected
returns that they can then use for
companies within that sector. the market
implied risk measures. And finally,
[clears throat] there are people who
argue that it's better to use risk
adjusted cash flows, though often I
don't think they quite know what they're
talking about because risk adjusting the
cash flows is not just taking bad
scenarios and building them into
expectations because expectations done
right should already do that. It's to
convert your expected cash flows into
what I call certainty equivalent cash
flow. You're saying, "What does that
even mean?" I don't know whether you've
ever seen the show called Let's Make a
Deal. It's a Howie Mandel's, you know.
And here's how the show goes. Um, the
contestant is offered two suitcases
which are closed. You can't see what's
in each suitcase. One suitcase contains
a million dollars. The other contains
nothing. And then Howie Mandel offers
them a fixed amount of money to walk
away. You think, well, that's easy.
Expected value is 500,000. Hey, that's
not that simple, right? Because we're
risk averse, we might accept 400,000
guaranteed instead of taking a risk that
we'll get nothing. That's a certain
equivalent cash flow. 400,000 is the
certain equivalent for that expected
500,000, the expected value of 500,000.
And the more risk averse we are, the
less we will accept to walk away. Now,
that's tough to apply in investing
because you don't have a single cash
flow in two suitcases. You have expected
cash flows over time. But there are
variants that people use out there. And
we'll talk more about these as we get
into investment philosophies. One is to
look at only those cash flows that are
safe, that are guaranteed. Many value
investors will not count a lot of
growth, calling it speculative. They're
looking at only the earnings and cash
flows you can count on. You're
effectively using a risk adjusted cash
flow. The second is, and this goes back
to Ben Graham, and the reason for the
focus on dividends in traditional value
investing is you assume that companies
pay out only what they can count on in
dividends because they're so afraid to
cut dividends. So, in effect, dividends
become your proxy for certain equivalent
cash flows. So, all variance on
traditional approaches, but here's the
bottom line. We can disagree about
equity risk but the one thing we should
all agree on is it matters to us as
equity investors. The risk measures can
be explicit as it they were with the
with traditional theory or database
models or implicit you know but either
way they've got to enter your decision
process. They can be quantitative but
I'm okay with qualitative. Now there are
in fact services that used to categorize
companies based on risk into you know
one to numbers from one to five or eight
through you know like bond ratings from
AA to I don't have a problem with that.
And finally you can have simple models
or complicated models. Take your pick
cuz whatever risk model you pick you
have to be comfortable with. So equity
risk is messier, more complex, more
complicated than fixed income risk. But
we have to get comfortable with it if we
want to invest in equities. I hope you
found this session useful and I thank
you for listening.